so as many of you know there have been
protests in front of the homes of
supreme court justices
it's overtly illegal it's like
unquestionably illegal to do this
because
free speech
is or i should say justice is more
important than free speech so we
basically the idea from the founding
fathers and in precedent is you can have
your free speech but courts need to
adjudicate and if you try to protest
picket parade or whatever in front of a
member of the court's home in an effort
to intimidate or change those
proceedings you are committing a crime
it is a slap on the wrist crime no one's
going to destroy your life over this
it's like up to a year in jail which
basically i think it's a misdemeanor i
don't know how they do the laws in in
in the federal at the federal level but
these people should be arrested they're
not being arrested and more importantly
we have gensake encouraging illegal
behavior now look i get it non-violent
civil disobedience i'm mostly cool with
but that means people get arrested and
these people are not getting arrested
take a look at this clip the post
millennial posted
just listen to jen seki yourselves
actually i think i got to fix i always
got to make sure i set the audio right i
already just doesn't play there we go
there we go so i know that there's an
outrage right now i guess about
protests that have been peaceful to date
and we certainly continue to encourage
that outside of judges homes and that's
the president's position
the president's position is to encourage
peaceful protests outside of judges
homes okay well i'm just gonna i'm real
quick i'm gonna read the law all right
18 u.s
usca 1507 whoever with the intent of
interfering with obstructing or impeding
the administration of justice or the
intent of influencing any judge juror
witness or court officer in the
discharge of his duty pickets or parades
in or near a building housing a court of
the united states or in or near a
building or residence occupied or used
by such judge juror witness or court
officer or with such intent using any
sound truck or similar device or resorts
to any other demonstration in or near
any such building or residence shall be
fined under this title or imprisoned not
more than one year or both nothing in
this section shall interfere with or
prevent the exercise by any court of the
united states of its power to punish for
contempt it quite literally says any
other demonstration now look i'm not
saying these people protesting should
get felony charges in life in prison i'm
saying when you engage in non-violent
civil disobedience we recognize you're
going to get arrested for it you're
going to get a fine you're probably
going to get court supervision the judge
is going to say you can't go back and
that's it you made your point you did
something that some people would find
crossing the line you get your
punishment for it but nothing's
happening i kind of just now listened to
it for like the second time or the third
time i realized when she says and we
encourage that that people are
misinterpreting that that they encourage
the outrage against it that people like
no that's what she meant that they
encouraged the outrage but she obviously
if you listen to the way she speaks is
encouraging the people being outside the
homes of the judges well that's i i
don't think anybody assumed otherwise
yeah she read it in text i could see how
it could get taken out let me let me
show you what the daily mail did on this
one they took her quote and they added
hyphens
to change the contacts which is amazing
they say
i know that there's an outrage right now
i guess about protests that have been
peaceful to date
paused and we certainly continue to
encourage that pause outside of judges
homes as if to imply she's really saying
if they're going to be protesting they
should be peaceful instead of saying she
encourages the protests themselves
outside of judges homes i mean what's
the point of protesting outside the
house of an unelected judge are you
going to give him a constitutional
argument he hasn't heard of it's an
intimidation tactic it's so obvious
doesn't matter it doesn't matter if it's
an intimidation or not it literally says
influence the court influencing any
judge juror witness or court officer if
you go outside of a court and you try to
influence the judge juror witness or
court officer you get in trouble for it
this is only and relates to like
physical buildings being outside because
like if you try and influence them
through the internet like create a
campaign of mass people emailing or
something that's legal well this is
specifically picketing or parading and
it says any other demonstration
yo i'm just saying i don't think it's
the apocalypse i think they definitely
shouldn't go to people's homes i think
that's over the line but i just think
when you get to the point where the
january 6 trespassers not the writers
the writers i get you arrest those guys
but the people who had the doors opened
who have been locked up in solitary for
like six months to a year or longer some
of these people
and then it turns out the judge is like
oh the cops let you in your case
dismissed
the the the boot that comes down
on the people on the right for basically
what what is a very similar law versus
the people who repeatedly and
continually do this and then are
encouraged to do it do it by the
president the disparity in law
enforcement is absolutely insane yeah i
don't want to assume but i would imagine
that if there was another law being
considered and that it was just
something joe biden wanted to get passed
and people were protesting outside
judges they'd have referenced this
immediately and went and arrested them
all i don't know but that's the feeling
of this partisanry could you imagine if
like
proud boys showed up to a judge's house
they'd get arrested immediately domestic
terrorists insurrectionists they're
trying to burn the country down that's
all you would hear from me and not only
that but
it wouldn't simply be the case that they
would get arrested they would start
digging through tweets from conservative
politicians who said that they were
against this potential decision and
tried to charge them with insurrection i
mean we would and we would never ever
hear the end of it we would never hear
the end of it it would be in the news
cycle repeatedly remember when those
proud boys went outside that judge's
house
but because it's the left doing it
nobody cares they tried to like frame it
as a vigil which is like a silent thing
where you're you're standing vigil at
night you're keeping an eye out and
scouting and you're quiet while you're
doing it but if they're making noise
outside their houses it's just a full-on
protest this is actually just a
continuation of the biden 2020 campaign
right where they said okay
every illegal immigrant can come across
and get free health care right they said
that in the democratic primary debate he
raised his hand kamala raised her hand
during the 2020 campaign as you guys
were talking about this week they bailed
out rioters in minnesota including
rapists and pedophiles so it's not a
surprise that they're encouraging
lawlessness themselves here that's just
that is the democratic party is
obviously the party of defunding the
police it's a party of not enforcing
laws at what point
do we just start acting like there is no
government
let me let me elaborate
the media lied about kyle rittenhouse
they repeatedly said that he shot and
killed black people which was just not
true
they lied about what happened they they
they they just it was it was insane
watching the actual trial and seeing
those lies and i'm like okay these
people can't be argued with they've made
this story up in fact the daily beast
used to be considered credible by
newsguard like 100 percent and then you
watch it slowly go down now they're
considered fake news at the right
exclamation point because they refuse to
correct all of the fake garbage they've
posted i wonder if the people at
newsguard which is like a news writing
agency are all getting red pilled like
crazy
because they're like the new york times
always tells the truth then they start
doing fact checking they're like guys
we had to actually fact check them and
they lied several times
so i'm looking at this
i'm looking at the the double standard
that you know we all perceive as people
who like the constitution and the
republic obviously there's no double
standard for the left because if it's
good for the revolution it's good if
it's bad for the revolution it's bad but
for us we're like hey we want laws
enforced equally i believe people have a
right to protest i believe you have a
right i i believe in leeway for
non-violent civil disobedience but you
at least expect there to be some
upholding the law so at what point
do people just say there's no point to
engage with the system
negotiate with
collaborate with or even
consider it would probably be starvat if
there was a mass starvation it would be
like a desperation thing if something
like that were to happen i just mean
like what happens if people stop
participating in national level politics
in any sense because they're like this
is pointless
that's why we have representatives
here's what i want to say
with roe v wade
as soon as these judges got in you saw a
bunch of red states start passing these
abortion restrictions
and the left was saying you know this is
illegal it violates precedent you can't
do this
but the states were like we're gonna do
it anyway we've continually seen this
throughout the past couple of years
where red states and blue states just do
whatever they want regardless of the
federal government it is kind of the
impetus of the united states say hey man
the king of king george was doing
whatever he wanted we were like yeah
we're going to do what we want so that's
the united states yeah i mean parties
are
generally selective
let it out sheamus you have i can tell
your point is gold thank you no
it's like going to be the most boring
point i've ever made
no pressure when it comes to sanctuary
cities exactly
exactly right
we have my translator
decriminalization of certain drugs
they're completely fine to find a
defying the federal government but
if you do so to protect unborn children
then that's illegal and they don't have
any respect for our political process
the the the issue right now
just i i i i everything keeps looping
back to the roe v wade thing because
that's what this protest is about but
it's conservatives are like states
should have the ability to choose and if
blue states want to pass you know
unrestricted abortion well then that's
their state's right that's that's
literally what the argument is right now
there are conservatives obviously saying
it should be banned out right but right
now in politics they're like return it
to the state legislatures and the left
is like no red states should be forced
to allow abortion
at what point do people just say like
dude we're not going to participate with
you anymore and we're going to do
whatever we want what are you going to
do about it california's doing it
already i'm going to try again um
so yes i think that's the point in large
part they want anyone who isn't on the
far left to stop participating that's
the whole idea you don't get a voice
this government isn't here to represent
you it's here to force the ideological
whims of a small minority of this
country onto you it's the purpose of the
political system at this point the irony
of that though and i'll hearken back to
this a lot over the course of my
campaign is the democratic party is
literally being run from people's
basements and from their living rooms
the government is not being run in
person this was one of the stories that
i wrote at the free beacon i walked all
around the capitol for about 11 miles
walking and just simply taking pictures
and taking videos pulling on doorknobs
of the democrats health committee which
is closed to prevent the spread of germs
which is impossible uh the senate armed
services committee we have some
conflicts going on in the world you
might have been aware of the foreign
relations committee democrats closed all
of the government is being run on zoom
which is a huge national security risk
right all of the democrats in congress
up until a couple weeks ago and the day
after my story posted chuck schumer
opened his office but so all of their dc
offices are closed all of their
constituent offices around the country
are closed so you're right they're
trying to force conformity but they're
also hiding from accountability because
if you have a problem with how your
democratic member of congress like the
guy i'm running against david trone you
literally can't access him you go to his
offices and this is true of democrats
around the country there's literally
mail just piling up you can write to
them you can be the most pro-life person
the most pro-choice person they
literally don't care they're hiding from
accountability they're using the
coronavirus to sort of be able to
withdraw from public criticism i just
think the system is just it's already
collapsed and we're kidding ourselves
that it hasn't it's changed we're for
sure using ancient ideas with modern
technology and it's not translating
because i think they they have a right
to work
remote you say that with an abacus in
front of your laptop i like it and i
will use it if the power goes out okay
that's part of why i have it um but
honestly i mean let's use the best
technology we have to communicate the
fastest the most efficient way possible
in my opinion and these these people are
still sending yeah but you need to be
able to talk to your representative
exactly
they need to be available to you that's
why like zoom like they should have an
hour day where they take video chat with
people public video chats that's the
only way they're trying to run the
government is by zoom and you know my
grandparents have no idea how to do that
if you're if you're in parts of western
maryland where there's horrible rural
broadband problems you you can't
function like this i know all about
horrible royal broadband problems yeah
it took us like six months to get
internet out here yeah crazy i mean we
had like we had low quality internet to
get business i mean it was nuts and with
the new space we're building it's just
it's really difficult that's west
virginia but here's the issue i don't i
don't like the idea of zoom government
yeah i don't i don't like the idea that
they don't need to look you in the eyes
and shake your hand and know you have
stood before them in their physical
space and said i live here and here's
what i expect from you that is important
like the king used to take court where
people would come in for several hours a
day and he'd be uh so bored just
listening to the problems be like okay
yeah you get the money okay yeah you're
the one in trouble and it works but it
doesn't scale when you have a three
million people that want to talk to the
guy the guy only has like you know 24
hours in a day i'll take a number the i
mean what are you gonna do it doesn't
matter if you're on zoom or otherwise
people can't if there's too many people
there's too many people the problem i
have and the reason why we don't do zoom
shows with irl is that it doesn't work
you don't get a real conversation i mean
you can have a conversation
it just it's not the same you can't it's
not the same but you can i had one of
michael mallis a couple weeks ago
episode 203 of you're welcome and it was
amazing amazing to have a chance to talk
to michael for an hour it was amazing
amazing technology but i think part of
it is the fact that you two agree or it
wasn't going to be a hostile
conversation if you're having a
conversation with someone you disagree
with it's much easier to operate in bad
faith and to just try to get dunks and
smacks in if you're communicating with
them digitally rather than face-to-face
there's a reason is the way that audio
doesn't translate its binary so if i
speak while you're speaking one of them
cuts out there's a reason why in my
opinion whenever we try and get
prominent left personalities on the show
they always say i'll do it on zoom and
it's because what they're going to do is
once we bring them on the show and go
live they're going to cut out and it's
going to be someone else
that's what they've done and that's what
they want to do they want to just
screw around
and so there have been a few people who
have agreed to come on this show that
we've had on the show from the from you
know prominent left influencers
but all these other ones are like hey
why don't i just do it digitally and i'm
like because we've seen what you guys do
when you do these things digitally i'll
point out as an aside it shouldn't be
zoom if we do this it should be open
source
non-proprietary so like jitsi or element
matrix or something like that but
um to add your point yeah man there's
definitely a risk involved but when it's
it's like if you need to listen to a
bunch of people from around the country
it just it makes more sense i think to
do it to telecommute it than to make
them all fly out to dc and wait for hour
a day that's no one having district
offices though right that you don't have
to go to the capitol and yet all of
these democrats around the country you
know you can go to the closest office
here it's probably 30 minutes away in
hagerstown closed been closed for two
years so i i think they they have to
physically go to dc
so they have to do all this
we're talking about the
i do not like the idea that they
telecommute to congress
and that's what they've been doing
and
you know it's it's like you see these
congressional hearings and like the tv
asked you a question sir
like no in regards to congress itself
they should be together in person i
agree because you get more out of a
human to human contact but for just
listening to people's concerned citizens
i think that could be at least try it
yeah yeah i mean if if a citizen's going
to make a phone call leave a voicemail
send a message i want to watch your
videos on youtube sure sure that's great
on rumble i just think
elected representatives need to be
available to their constituents bingo
and pelosi under her rules in the house
they have been wildly abusing the proxy
voting system where you as a
representative say i can't come and vote
in person due to the coronavirus and i
reported on this extensively about the
abuses of the proxy voting system you'd
have eric swalwell saying that i can't
vote due to the coronavirus he'd be jet
setting around the country you pull his
campaign finance reports he's spending
in lavish hotels you have other
congressmen who are saying i can't
currently vote they're posting about how
they're in atlanta with joe biden for
mlk day so the proxy voting system has
been rampantly abused and it lets
democrats just thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 p.m and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you